and now we have women that they're
really they're giving them diversity
hires and it's obvious to everyone
around them that their diversity hires
because really women can't handle stress
like men can you know and a lot of
people it's so funny a lot of people
look to me as an example be like Pearl
aren't you like doing this high stress
job I'm like
I talk for a living do you think that's
as hard as building a building do you
think I you I have it in me to go build
that building next door oh no
oh no no no no I'm like I talk and I
tweet now don't get me wrong there's
some things that are stressful I am a
hard worker but to compare that to the
real dirty jobs of this Society like do
you remember the show Dirty Jobs and I
actually have an issue because a lot of
the streamers will look down on the men
that do these dirty jobs as if they are
somehow better more confident or smarter
than them you know and I think it's
really a disservice to the men that do
those jobs that allow us to do what we
do and it's also a disservice um to the
women
where we get in these jobs and think we
can do it when we we certainly cannot I
have no problem with women doing things
that we that we're good at right but the
problem is we keep pushing women into
things that we're bad at and I'm
wondering why we suck at everything so
I'll give you guys an example when I was
in high school
um I remember a guy
um telling me he scored much better on
the acts than one of my friends and at
the time he said she only got into that
school because she's a woman
and I said what no that like you're just
bitter whatever and I kind of wrote it
off and a couple years later I thought
to myself
as he's doing a now today is doing a
much harder job than she is I think to
myself yeah she did get into that school
because she was a woman she was smart
right I wasn't gonna get in I don't want
to say the school but I'm like I they
would not have taken my application let
me tell you she's smarter than me but
the truth of the matter is men are
overlooked for jobs that they deserve
because they want to hand them to women
and as women we got to push back against
this and and say that we are tired
of being pandered to because the women
that do work for these positions now it
looks like they're diversity hires and
we can't tell the difference
um so here here's an example so in
Russia there was a Russian space agency
and this surprises me from Russia has
threatened to press charges against the
NASA astronaut who claimed it drilled
two millimeter holes in a soyuz ms-09
vehicle that was docked at the
International Space Station in 2018. the
agency recently completed its
investigation into what it deems was a
Savage
citing senoria and non-chancellor a crew
member of the ISS at the time of the
incident as the culprit the allegations
have been handed over to a Russian law
enforcement allowing ruskahoma to
announce the possibility of criminal
charges the asvesta newspaper reported
on Friday citing sources that a
non-chancellor made the whole with the
hopes of an early return okay this is
again again because and this isn't to
hate women but it's genuinely to
understand us she she says I miss home I
want to go home I want to go home she's
not thinking logically she's not
thinking of the any of the consequences
it's just the way I feel first
and this is what she does
um you know it's funny when Matt can
make crimes a lot of the crimes are just
a little more logical I mean they're all
emotional right I mean usually it's the
sign of an emotional man but usually
it's like there's some upside like what
is the upside like there's a tremendous
downside from drilling a hole
into
this the station that you're in
there there is a tremendous downside
um the upside is okay she gets to go
home early
there's like not even cat like when men
rob a bank there's an upside you know
what I mean sources told the Russian
news outlet that a non-chancellor wanted
to leave the orbiting laboratory due to
a blood clot or fight with her boyfriend
on board the ISS so however a
non-chancellor was married to Jeff
Chancellor when she was in space and the
two were still married to this day so
it's unclear who the boyfriend was as
stated by Russian insiders so again
that's female nature we just tend to
date and sleep with the Men At Work the
bosses the upper right now
I'm not saying every woman will
some women are you know have the morals
or whatever but in a society where we
really have little to no morals what's
stopping chicks it's not like we have a
religious Society
Daily Mail has reached out to NASA for
more information as yet and has yet to
receive a response according to a report
in Tass
roscom's most Insider claims there were
multiple holes drilled by someone
unfamiliar with the module design
without proper support to ensure
accurate Drilling and low gravity the
hole was spotted on August 30th 2018
after a pressure drop was identified due
to an air leak Russian cosmots quickly
pegged the hole and restored the
pressure patching it up with several
layers of exposure reslin a glue-like
substance okay after the hole was sealed
cosmonauts carried out the photo and
video surveillance of the whole using an
endoscope the Russian official in
September 2018 said that the whole
appeared to have punctured using a drill
and could have been caused deliberately
by someone on the ground Russia opened
an investigation into what caused the
hole in 2019 and shared allegations in
August that a non Chancellor made the
hole NASA responded by saying it does
not comment on medical matters but
disputed the claim describing the
astronaut as extremely well respected
and making many invaluable contributions
now again guys a lot women are master
manipulators you know again this is just
a woman nature thing it's not saying
every woman's gonna manipulate you but
it's kind of something that we just keep
in the back of our head like that just
kind of how women are uh Bill Nelson
head of NASA posted on Twitter in August
I fully support Serena
simping White Knight however the latest
development now opens the doors for
Russia's Ross camosis to press charges
against a non-chancellor NASA claimed
the astronauts on board were never in
danger of Suffocation due to the
Lifeboat spacecraft attachment to the
stallion to provide a return to Earth
later images and further investigation
revealed the hole had been made from the
inside ruling out space debris as the
cost
um Sergey Pro copayv and the other two
astronauts a non-chancellor of NASA and
Alexander jurst of European Space Agency
were on board as was detected the
allegation against a non-chancellor was
made in the article published t-a-s-s
claiming to debunk 12 things Americans
Claim about the Russian space space
agency they report it would not have
been possible for the damage to happen
on Earth as the ship would have never
passed vacuum chamber tests essential to
the flight being ready if there were any
holes in it than the pressure in the
ship would immediately drop and it would
not pass the appropriate test thus Ross
camosis immediately ruled out the
version of damage to the soyuz ms019 on
Earth tasks reported it then goes on to
discuss the mental health of a
non-chancellor suggesting she took
drastic action action to speed up her
return to Earth so yeah there you go
again it's a woman not being held
accountable if a man did this what do
you think would happen guys in general
and again this is why we just got to
take women out of these super high
stress jobs we can't do it and you know
um I'll I'll
say occasionally we have women that come
through but guys it's the exception it's
not the rule and we always always always
need to make sure I almost think women
need to pass more tests and go through
more rigorous training to make sure we
don't succumb to our biology I'm gonna
predict
guys guys and I fly a lot so I really
hope I'm not on one of these freaking
planes but I'm gonna predict that we're
gonna start seeing planes crashing
because we're they're letting women fly
these planes luckily I mean they're
mostly you know done on their own but I
I don't want to be on planes where women
are the pilots no thank you keep me off
of those I mean because again we process
everything emotions first especially
when it's high stress women cannot
handle stress like men can